what is mathematical induction
mathematical induction is a method of
proof so sometimes you'll see the phrase
by induction it's in the same category
of maths as its other more well-known
umbrella which is deduction right so
we've seen you know deductive geometry
right it's a kind of logic that you use
to start with something that you know
and establish something else okay to
prove something right
apart from deduction the other main way
was not really a main way but you've
used it sometimes is a proof by
contradiction right we saw that a little
bit in inequalities and there's a famous
proof by contradiction for why square
root numbers why they irrational if you
remember that you don't have to know it
now but just to know that there's
different ways of proving things so
induction is an important one now
it deals mainly with what we call they
are discrete numbers just numbers which
is another way of saying whole numbers
discrete math as a whole the branch of
Matz mainly so most of the questions
you're going to be looking at are
integers and positive integers okay
there are a few applications as
mathematical inductions that are very
that are different to that but this is
okay so let me give me anything here is
a typical statement that I'm going to
show you you can prove I'm pickier
because it's an AP and you guys know how
to do a piece so we're going to prove
this by deduction in a second and then
I'm going to show you how proof by
induction works differently okay so
here's a statement okay one plus three
plus five and so on up to
[Music]
this is the series of odd numbers right
it's equal to N squared
now I'm going to show you how to prove
this by induction but before we get onto
that just so you know it's actually not
a read mystical thing I was really
confused by it when I was doing music 12
it's just another tool in your tool well
okay so I'm gonna use deduction
deductive logic to prove this after you
can't sue okay how'd you go about it if
the question was this this what would
you do well be a first step
why is there going to be a problem with
using your calculator for this
calculator is a really good concrete
values right I'm better than you are
actually and me they're not so good at
indeterminate things I don't know how
long this series is this use could be
anyway okay how do I prove this by
deduction well on a sample left-hand
side okay and you guys know you
recognize this because we've spent a
whole topic on this right you would say
it's 1 plus 3 plus 5 plus so on right
you could classify this right you could
say it's an average series I think way
back to your first lesson on series and
sequences right and we talked about how
you define a series what are the two
piece of information that define this
particular series AMD right its first
term so then how many series where the
first term is 1 and it's common
difference ears and it's 1 in terms but
you sort of Orion
now therefore I can say the left-hand
side is equal to true now I know a
formula for working out the son
or an arithmetic series right oh yeah I
can evaluate it okay what's it equal to
we pair them up so at the front was yet
ha n right
okay and then in here we had two a plus
or yes you could you could use that you
could use the last term as well that
would work here as well okay but since I
know what these two are I'm just gonna
go with it that's equal to the number of
terms is still in okay 2a is just 2
what have I got here n minus 1 lots of
food this is a half on the outside and
then there's a 2 here and 2 there so I'm
just gonna multiply through by that so
God and then outside of 1 plus that's n
times in da-da-dun true statement ok so
that's not too bad okay but we ran into
some problems number one you need to
know stuff about average series to use
this logic okay number two if it assumes
what sorry it's not again it only works
on a series where it's as mate or later
on a geometric what if I were to give
you a different kind of series right APs
and GPS are very very specific and we're
gonna look at all kinds of series which
follow all different kinds of weed rules
ok all this knowledge is great but it
will break down and won't help you there
ok so I'm going to show you how you can
prove by induction we use the same
example so you can see how does it work
there are four steps to every proof by
induction and it wouldn't be a lesson by
me unless there was some kind of corny
acronym to remember them by okay so
here's my uh here's my helpful thing to
help you remember okay I was considering
it throw this at someone and then really
remember I can throw it all in the same
time so I'm just gonna show it to you
okay so my acronym but how to prove
something by induction is I'm gonna
let's put in another color show because
it's it's tape tape okay I'm gonna walk
you through these four steps okay
they're the same every single time by
like this one did anyone bring Domino's
I also want to bring Domino's didn't
have any okay that's right you can even
bring them later I don't know I want you
to catch this person
okay so tape
how does this work for this guy did
you're trying this it's pretty hard okay
so oh not bad the first is more tests
okay I'm going to explain what these
artists in this game Tifa test a for now
this is interesting so far I've been
telling you our soldiers are bad right
assumptions make an ass of you and me
don't do it okay
you'll see why hopefully this is a have
you never seen em before
anyway usually assumptions are bad but
inductions rely on assumptions okay by
the way out of the three methods of
proof I just told you about proof by
contradiction also relies on assumptions
doesn't it you assume something and then
you prove I can't possibly be you'll
have connection okay the third step is
where all the work is people prove okay
and I'll show you exactly what you have
to prove soon and the last thing which
is really just a formality
is to explain something okay and you'll
see you really will see it's really just
now by the way sometimes people will put
numbers next to these okay and then when
they're actually doing their real proof
they'll put the numbers there um I don't
think that's a bad idea
it'll make sure you know you have a
mission of step that kind of thing but
if you have tape in your head then
hopefully better work okay
so test what are we testing the first
thing is to test the statement right so
this is all about proving statements
right
this is the statement I'm going to test
the statement for its first possible
value its first possible value now
usually that's N equals one okay
usually N equals one occasionally it's N
equals zero sometimes they'll give your
statement and only works for like four
and up or 500 or whatever okay the key
is that has some first possible value
and we're gonna test it to see if it
worked
so here's a statement right so I say it
left hand side for N equals 1 okay I
should probably put that in prove that
this is true and so okay positive
integers so this this part really easy
all you do is evaluate it okay so what
have I got here
well if I've just got N equals 1 how
many terms will I have just one right
and it'll be of this form 2 n minus 1
which they actually already give to us
right so I would say 2n minus 1 equals 2
times 1 plus 1 which is 1 trivial okay
like I said mr. work is here as you're
saying it right hand side N squared is
equal to 1 squared which is equal to 1
and that's equal to the left hand side
therefore the state is true
or N equals one okay now it may have a
same point like why are we doing this
it's so simple
okay as you'll see later on these other
bits they're sort of useless if you
don't have the earlier steps in there
they seem trivial okay all right now
that's done because I'm run out today so
I'm just gonna put this out put her down
what's the second thing we want to
assume and this is often called the
inductive step is where that's help or
needed number to assume the statement is
true for a certain value and we're going
to call that value okay it's just the
constant any close to be like assume a
stupid statement is true for N equals K
ie right so this is not therefore right
there's no there's no logic that says
this is true I didn't know it's true I'm
this assuming it is right but what that
looks like is what the line started with
the statement but instead of ends you'll
have a cat that's in okay I'm just
assuming it's true and we're gonna work
with this okay okay now now the real
work starts prove what do we have to
prove I want to prove if this is true
right if it's true for some robot I want
to prove that the same is true for the
next number
now if the first number is K what's the
next level okay like I said this is
dealing with integers okay so in other
words what do I want to prove I want to
prove that this thing all about 2k plus
1 so it's gonna go it's gonna start off
the same it's gonna have all those same
in-between terms it's gonna get to this
term 2 K minus 1 right but then I've got
to go one more term that's the k plus 1
part okay so careful with your own your
brackets and that kind of thing every
see the cake put the brackets there so
you expand it right so this is gonna be
two outside okay there's my left-hand
side I want to prove that that's equal
to and what will the my hands a bit you
know just try to substitute it right to
everywhere I saw em I'm now gonna see
okay plus one it's all square okay now
I'm gonna try and prove this is true
assuming that this is true okay now
remember I don't know if this is true or
not I'm just assumed you knew it what
does it look like well I say you can
start on either side just like with your
trig and any proofs right sometimes it's
easier to start at this side sometimes
it's easy stuff on this side with um
with proof by induction almost always
it's on the left-hand side and you'll
see why in a second okay so now
left-hand side I'm gonna say that's
equal one plus three plus five and so on
CK minus one
okay yeah and you can see why we do this
series these questions often to deal
with series can you see in this line
that I'm looking at this is familiar
right we've dealt with most of this line
before see this part you may actually
want to do it yourself in another color
see that there right this is what we
were looking at in step two this is this
is what the assumption was dealing with
we assume that that is equal to this
okay so I'm gonna substitute that
entirely okay so I'm gonna get K squared
that's what I assumed it was equal to
right plus I guess I can start doing
some expansion over here that's 2 k plus
2 minus 1 okay now because this step is
so important this is the step which
makes the induction work if you like I'm
you have to draw attention to it so
rather just substitute you can say by
assumption okay
okay and now I want to finish my proof I
want to arrive at this point sorry with
this point that's where I want to finish
okay there's my right hand son come and
get to it and you can see in this
example this is partly why I chose it
it's not that hard
this two K plus 2 minus 1 is 2 k plus 1
ok so where the plus 2 k plus one and
that's just factorization ok now can you
see this is why I was trying to get
Domino's right can you see what has just
been established this is really all the
work that's been done okay what a
Domino's look like ok and the idea is
that if you push one bottom in it at
least if you put them in the right spots
right if you push one dollar though
it'll push all the subsequent lines
right that's the idea steps 2 & 3 are
like pushing your Domino okay
saying look if I can make one of them
for load bar the next one will fall over
to okay if this one can fall so will the
next one right so in other words it's
sort of looking at your Domino's and say
look see there's distances they're all
pretty small bill all four if I push one
of them okay
and now can you see why the first step
even though so trivial is is really sort
of it's the foundation right the first
step testing that is true for the first
one is saying now look I can push the
first one right I just proved that it
can be pushed okay so you push the first
one and if the first one goes then
according to step 3 the next one should
also go and the next one and so on right
and forever okay and if I had Domino's I
set them up okay sure
I'm sort of done right all that's left
is to say that part but you know
concluded okay
so here's part four
I would say the statement sorry if the
statement is true for N equals K that's
step two right then it is also true for
N equals k plus 1 right and that then is
crucial right we relied on that factor
in step two to be able to prove step
three okay
however we proved at in step one right
the state is true for its first value
namely what and again that that power
will change depending on therefore the
statement is true form
and me now you see what's going on I
already proved it's true for one but if
it's true for K let k equal to one
therefore it's also true for K plus 1 1
plus 1 which is 2 and that implies it's
gonna be true for the next one and so on
which is exactly what we meant okay
sometimes you may need to prove put on
the end ie or positive integers and if
you want to be a real nerd if you can
say set notation ie for n is this is an
element of this set of positive
continues Sandia well that kind of
implies it right positive integers what
are the positive integers well these are
positive and there is no other values I
couldn't fit into oh yeah yeah yeah that
I've done it for integers in the screen
o equals 1 okay
exhale four steps is just take okay now
I this bit at the end right it's a
little bit like you know what you have
to prove an absolute maximum or an
absolute minimum and again you have this
kind of essay I've got no other
stationary points it's continuous blah
blah right this is really long and
here's the important thing right
unlike the the differentiation one right
which sometimes it varies sometimes
you've got discontinuities sometimes you
don't sometimes you've got other
stationary points sometimes you don't
unlike those situations this statement
is identical every single time right
it's always that the statement is true
for N equals K and therefore K minus 1
and you always start the first value
therefore it's always true for all over
okay so get this so that one of the only
times this happens and that's
particulars all of this you can replace
and you can say
why what would you stop is that is a
logical proof right it's the principle
of mathematical induction okay by the
principle of mathematical induction the
same is true for whichever there is a
plan okay now the reason why I don't
just show you that at the beginning is
because you do need to understand what
it really stands for okay
this whole domino idea right that you've
proved it for any next value and then
you pick one the first one and say I can
make them all fall okay but this is
actually all you have to write okay